china has long been criticized for its
human rights abuses against ethnic and
religious minorities and the winter
olympics is underway right now in
beijing and has sparked a widespread
outcry when did this abuse actually
begin well here's a quick history lesson
forced labor mass sterilization torture
and sexual abuse
uighurs and kazakhs are among the groups
suffering at the hands of the communist
country in xinjiang the holocaust
memorial museum even comparing the
ongoing genocide to the nazis
persecution of 6 million jews
primarily muslim ethnic minority groups
make up more than half of xinjiang's
population of 25 million the largest
being uyghurs
they did get their independence briefly
in the early 20th century but china's
new communist government took it all
away in 1949. conqueror of china
communist general mao tsi tung is
welcome to p king to review his
victorious forces
[Music]
the group was then named one of the
country's recognized ethnic minorities
leading to the xinjiang uyghur
autonomous region in 1955
but in 2009 violent riots broke out
around 200 people killed
the chinese blaming the deadly protest
on wagers claiming they want their own
state
but that hope was dashed for the
perceivable future when violence erupted
in march of 2014 uyghur separatists blew
up a railway station killing 31 wounding
141 chinese president xi jinping elected
to take severe action
documents leaked to the new york times
revealed he directed local officials to
respond with quote absolutely no mercy
these reports are consistent with an
overwhelming and growing body of
evidence that the chinese communist
party is committing human rights
violations and abuses against
individuals in mass detention what does
china call them re-education camps
claiming it was the only way they could
stop separatism and terror in the region
what's the result unimaginable ongoing
torture nothing short of genocide
china still operates an estimated 1200
of those concentration camps in xinjiang
province these prisoners are raped
they're beaten they're tortured my next
guest survived one of those so-called
re-education camps saragul satbe worked
for the chinese government as a civil
servant back in 2014 was planning to
flee china but the communist government
confiscated her passport she was
concerned for the safety of her husband
and her kids so she sent them away and
cut off communication the government
then kidnapped her and forced her to
work in a prison reeducation camp
working with inmates about the chinese
language about the chinese culture and
chinese politics she was released in
2018 and then reunited with her family
joining us right now for an exclusive
interview through her interpreter in
sweden is the doctor and educator who
survived that re-education camp we've
been telling you about sarah goes sought
by thanks so much for joining me
what should america know
about what is going on in xinjiang
province
this genocide still is going on so i
keep in touch with people in the
kazakhstan who has a relative in china
so they still they confirmed that about
the
site in china
it's happening witnesses have said it's
happening china denies it's happening
but in terms of details of the horror i
know it's traumatic
but what you talk about is 20 prisoners
living in one room they're handcuffed
they're head shaved every move is
monitored by cameras a bucket is their
toilet their daily routine they learn
chinese memorize propaganda and confess
to invented sins
they range in age from teenagers to the
elderly they eat bad stuff their
fingernails are pulled out they get
electric shocks they're forced
sterilization
is all that true
there's still people in the
concentration cup and i do confirm that
it's still happening and there is a
still problem over the all muslims
in the chinese com a communist party
so here's what the chinese embassy
said in response to your claims
they say you're lying
of course they will deny this genocide i
have to i have to say i have to speak
publicly uh they will keep telling that
this genocide is over the muslim it's
it's not happening there because of the
politics of the the re-education
re-education school as an institute but
this is another education school or
institute as i they said this is a
genocide over the all people
one of the worst things you said that
you have seen
is 200 inside inmates on the outside men
and women told of the women to confess
their sins one woman stood there before
us declared that she had been a bad
person but now that she had to confess
her sins she had learned chinese and she
had become a better person when she was
done speaking the policeman ordered her
to disrobe and simply raped her
yeah
yes she witnessed that situation with
the young woman you also said you got
your hands on some top secret chinese
information about what the china
china chinese nation wants to do in the
world
number one
assimilate or eliminate
america
annexed neighboring countries
occupation of europe
that's their goal this is their
three-prong goal
what document did you see
how authentic do you think it is
i saw this document and i witnessed it
that this document is real
do you
believe that
other nations should be attending the
beijing olympics are you shocked that
everybody is attending these olympics
i do not agree with this olympic games
dictatorship is still going on so there
is no reason to go to the olympics games
the hiding the genocide
how did you get out of the camp how did
you get out of the country they sent me
back to the home as a
as a as mini vacation
i was a witness of the death so if i
realized if they will get me back to the
camp i will die so i decided to run away
and i ran away from the chinese
governing country and then i will decide
to speak publicly
so why is it
that the muslim the muslim world the
islamic world has not risen up to
support you
and uh and expressed their outrage about
these camps why are they so silent
the reason of the why the all muslim
other countries is silent is because of
that there is many loans and debs was
taken from the china
thanks so much for telling your story
hopefully the world is taking notice
stay safe in sweden
thank you for more of syragul's story i
want you to check out her book it's
called chief witness it's available
right now hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now